hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
section 11 of David hume's inquiry
concerning human understanding is title
of Providence and a future State and he
is going to discuss both of those in the
course of this section probably much
more about Providence and when we hear
that term we should bring to mind the
idea of a deliberate and thoughtful
arrangement of matters within the
universe that concern us that concern
everything else within the universe when
we talk about providential ordering
we're meaning that there's some sort of
purpose of
arrangement of things so that things
work together well right so we can talk
about their being order or structure or
Fitness we might even say within the
universe and then we can also talk about
other things like does Justice exist
within this world is it a fair world
that's also a matter of Providence and
then the future State issue would come
in if the world itself isn't fair enough
and we've got a god well then God would
you know take care of all of our merits
or demerits later on we're not going to
worry so much about that right now
because there's some key issues that we
need to explore as David Hume is setting
the stage for us and this is a
particularly interesting section from a
rhetorical perspective one of the tricks
that Hume often does is when he's he's
attacking religion and you know a sort
of philosophy oriented around religion
which is quite common in his time
he will instead of saying here's the
arguments against it uh this is exactly
what I believe he will say you know uh
somebody might say this sort of thing
and of course I don't buy into this
myself but let's take a look at their
arguments anyway we see him doing this
in a number of different places and he's
doing that here in this work he says at
the beginning I was engaged in
conversation with a friend who loves
skeptical paradoxes he Advanced many
principles which I by no means approve
yet as they seem to be curious and bear
some relation to the chain of reasoning
carried on in this inquiry I'll copy
them from my memory as accurately as I
can in order to submit them to the
Judgment of the reader so I'm going to
put forth what my friend had to say and
now it's going to get even more
convoluted because his uh you know
they're talking about the Good Fortune
of philosophy and then they're talking
about out you know it's connection with
Leisure and freedom and they're talking
about Athens uh you know other than the
banishment of protagoras and The Death
of Socrates you know Athens was was a
pretty good place epicurus lived at
Athens to an advanced age in peace and
tranquility and epicureans were even
allowed even though they had rather
heterodox beliefs about things to
participate in the religious framework
of that society and even in the Roman
Empire and so his friend says you admire
the singular as the singular Good
Fortune of philosophy what seems to
result from the natural course of things
and be unavoidable in every age and
Nation you know
um philosophy itself is often
responsible for the pertinaceous bigotry
which seems to be fatal to philosophy
what if epicurus was persecuted what if
he had to give an accounting for himself
the way that Socrates did and if you
think back to the trial of Socrates what
was he actually on trial for corruption
of the young but also for impiety that
is holding heterodox religious beliefs
about the nature of the Gods and the
universe
what would epicurus say if he was going
to defend his own point of view about
religion and we should mention that the
epicureans didn't actually believe that
gods don't exist they in fact thought
there were Gods but those gods have zero
connection with human life that is why
the gods are actually Happy Blessed
untroubled they don't get involved in
human Affairs or the running of the
universe so you could say that you know
practically speaking what are these are
these remotely like the gods that
typical religious people think about no
so this could be a kind of practical
Atheism in any case epicurus right is
giving this speech and he's talking
about the religious philosophers you
know he's going to address not the
ordinary people but those who you know
can be reasoned with and so he says that
we're not going to dispute concerning
the origin and government of Worlds the
religious philosopher is not satisfied
with the tradition of your forefathers
and doctrine of your priests indulge a
rash curiosity in trying to see how far
they can establish religion on the
principles of reason so they're trying
to sort of have their cake and eat it
too to use that old expression they want
to have the doctrines about the gods
including that the gods take care of the
world or God does but they also want to
establish this using argument and reason
and you could say you know looking at
the universe in an empirical way so they
think that within the universe we can in
fact discern some sort of Divine
Providence
so they they painted the most
magnificent colors the order Beauty and
wise arrangement of the universe and
then they ask if such a glorious display
of intelligence could proceed from the
fortuitous Concourse of atoms or if
chance could produce what the greatest
genius cannot sufficiently admire now
why are they talking about atoms well
the epicureans were atomists and they
thought that everything really is atoms
and their interactions and there is some
Randomness that allows us you know
Freedom this is their metaphysics and so
these people are saying Epicurean
metaphysics doesn't work look at the
universe you can see how wonderfully
arranged it is must be that there are
gods or God and so he calls this uh the
main or the chief or Soul argument for a
Divine existence derived from what the
order of nature what do you see in
nature he says there are pure marks of
Intel agents and design that you think
it extravagant to a sign for its cause
either chance or the Blind and unguided
force of matter and what is going on
here if we think about it in a very
generic sense
from a human perspective and the
perspective that is being given to
epicurus what these people are doing is
looking at effects things that that
occur and saying there must be a cause
for these effects and the effects are
not just the singular things but the way
that they're arranged together the way
that they're fitted together in some
sort of ordering that seems to make
sense therefore there must be a cause
that produced this so they're inferring
the cause from the effect now
when when do we do this sometimes we
infer causes from effects that we
understand the relation between quite
well you know constant conjunction right
in this case
we've got the cause only known from its
effects
so we're it's not like a case of where
there's smoke there's fire this is more
where there's arrangement in the
universe there must be a God as the
cause of that
how much could we possibly know about
this cause he says from the order of the
work you and further must have been
project and forethought in the work
person if you cannot make this out you
allow your conclusion fails and so Hume
has his his character say when we infer
any particular cause from an effect we
must proportion the one to the other and
we can never be allowed to ascribe to
any cause
qualities but what are exactly
sufficient to produce the effect and he
gives the example of like bodies and
stuff like that and so he says this same
rule what is the rule we cannot ascribe
to it for their qualities or assume it
capable of producing other effects
because we don't actually know the same
rule holds whether the cause the sign be
brood unconscious matter or a rational
intelligent being if the cause he says
be known only for by the effect we ought
never to ascribe to it qualities beyond
what are precisely requisite to produce
the effect nor can we by any just rules
of reasoning return back from the cause
and infer other effects from it so what
is the upshot of this
well we if we want to say that there's
gods or a God that produce this you know
order in the universe
we can only infer that the gods have the
qualities that we see reflected in their
works that's all we can know about them
because we're just relying on you know
our observation and on reason right so
he says that
um you know if we think about uh zaoxis
who is a great artist in ancient Greece
I mean as epicurus talking to Athenians
he says nobody merely from the site of
one of douxus's pictures could know that
he was also a statuary or architect and
was an artist no less skillful and Stone
and Marble than in colors the talents
and tastes displayed in the particular
work before us these we may safely
conclude the workmen to be possessed of
the cause must be proportioned to the
effect
so he says if we allow the gods to be
authors of the existence or order of the
universe it follows here's what we can
actually say about them they possess
that precise degree of power
intelligence and benevolence which
appears in their workmanship nothing
further can be proved he says unless
we bring in some other things you know
like Leslie says flattery an
exaggeration to supply the defects of
argument and reasoning and he's going to
talk about all sorts of other
smuggling in assumptions if we're just
going with observation and experience
all we can say about the gods as workmen
of this world or God as the creator of
the world is what we can infer from the
world itself the world that we observe
so you know how much can we actually
infer about this world I mean does it
appear to be all that well organized you
know perfectly uh suited everything is
connected to everything else you know he
he'll say at some point
um
think think about all the fruitless
industry to account for the ill
appearances of Nature and save the honor
of the Gods while we must acknowledge
the reality of the evil and disorder
which the world so much abounds and
people might make up excuses for this he
brings up the obstinate and intractable
qualities of matter or the observance of
general laws right this is why Jupiter
you know God obliged him to create
Mankind and every sensible creature so
imperfect and so unhappy now notice what
he's doing there if we can only infer
things about the cause from the effects
and the universe isn't actually this
harmonious perfect uh well-arranged
thing but it's actually kind of a mess
what can we infer oh that there's a
perfect designer behind it
Maybe not maybe this actually proves
that if there is a God that God is not a
particularly great or attentive or
thoughtful workmen right so that's
that's kind of a problem here
um we we infer the qualities of the
deity in in its works right
he also is stressing here that listen
we can't
legitimately look at just the effects
reason to the cause and then descend
back from the cause in inferences to the
effects so we can't like look at the
universe and say well it seems like it's
a mess but you know insofar as it's got
order there must be like a great
designer who is you know providentially
thinking about all this and therefore
there must in fact be order that we're
not Discerning in it humans say that's
you know you can believe that if you
want but you don't have good rational
reasons for that right and uh
this is this is going to be kind of a
problem he goes on and he says the
religious hypothesis must be considered
only as a particular method of
accounting for the visible phenomena of
the universe so what does that mean it's
only one of several different
possibilities for explaining what it is
that we actually observe in the universe
we could also explain it on the basis of
atoms or chance or pick whatever else
you might want he says no just Reasoner
will ever ever presume to infer it from
any single fact an altar or add to the
phenomena in any single particular right
so you know he says where then is the
hatefulness the odiousness of the
doctrine which I teach in my school you
know where where are you seeing a
problem with this I deny a Providence
you say and supreme governor of the
world who guides the course of events
and punishes The Vicious Etc et cetera
et cetera and we're going to get into
that more in a different discussion but
the point here is that
there's alternative explanations right
and then Hume actually
considers a possible objection after
this nice speech by uh epicurus that's
uh discussed here
um and he says and this is you know
probably familiar to many of us I
observe said I finishing he'd finish he
finished his harangue that you neglect
not the artifice of the demagogues of
old you know you're making rhetorical
arguments but let me propose this if you
saw a half-finished building surrounded
with heaps of brick and stone and mortar
and all the instruments of masonry could
you not infer from the effect that it
was a work of design and contrivance
that is an interesting uh sort of
analogy here right because why is Hume
using this I mean the next thing that
he's going to say is the very familiar
uh one about if you saw on the seashore
the print of one human foot you would
conclude that a man had passed that way
and that he'd also left the traces of
the other foot now that's sort of saying
well you know we see some effects we
reason to the causes so you know it's a
familiar argument from design but this
is an argument from design that takes
into account the fact that the Universe
does seem to be kind of a mess right we
see a half finished building
a building that's you know good in some
parts not good in other parts and then
we see like the raw materials
scattered around or perhaps not even
scattered maybe piled around and say ah
this one isn't quite done but it's
clearly the work of an intelligent
designer right so we've got this
argument from design that's you know
very familiar to many people in the
philosophy of religion he says that you
know if you see something that looks
like design a fact you can infer the
designer as a a Cause
and then the question is does this
actually
allow us to say that there is indeed a
designer and here Hume is going to bring
out one of his favorite arguments that
he makes in other places so this
objection is actually handled
by the fact that there is such a big
difference between human matters
we can rightly judge that there's human
intentionality and design there and
whatever it is that the deity or the
Divinity is and the universe so he says
that the infinite difference of the
subjects is a sufficient foundation for
this difference in my conclusions this
is his friend talking in works of human
art and contrivance it is allowable to
advance from the effect of the cause and
returning back from the cause to form
new inferences concerning the effects
why well because we know a lot about
human beings from experience so we can
go back and forth between causes and
effects like that right so he says that
we know that people from experience the
motives and Designs were acquainted with
whose projects and inclinations have a
certain connection and coherence
according to the laws which nature is
established for the government of such a
creature but
what about God
we don't actually know anything about
God he says the deity is known to us
only by his production so go back to
this you cannot go further than
inferring the cause from the effects and
the you can only infer in the cause what
actually shows up in the effects so he
says the day is only known by his
Productions
even more is a single being in the
universe not comprehended under any
species or genus now this is not a
radically new doctrine Thomas Aquinas
actually says stuff like this so do
other people in the history of
Christianity so this is taking religious
philosophy and saying well the
conclusions that must follow from this
are you know not what you would expect
right so there's an infinite difference
between the subjects of the human beings
plural versus God
he says the print of you know a foot in
the sand yeah that works just fine but
we can't refer to we can't look at the
universe and then automatically infer
attributes or qualities in God he says
as the universe shows wisdom and
goodness we infer wisdom and goodness as
it shows a particular degree of these
Perfections we infer that particular
degree but further attributes we can
never be authorized to infer or suppose
by any rules of just reasoning
we can't go any further so uh the
analogies
Hume points out that we are relying on
analogy the analogies that would have to
do with the Divine being are incredibly
arbitrary and weak we cannot tell much
about uh Divinity on the basis of what
we observe in the universe now as I
pointed out all of this is being
attributed either to his friend or to
epicurus Hume says oh I'm not saying
this myself but this is in fact hume's
Doctrine we cannot legitimately
rationally infer anything you know that
we would we would have great confidence
in about their being an intelligent
designer by looking merely at the
universe we can we can have faith in
that if we want to we can engage in
imagination and fancy we can allow
ourselves to be convinced by other
peoples hearsay but we don't have any
good rational grounds according to Hume
to think that the the universe is in
fact
providentially ordered or arranged